[Music]
just imagine that you are a farmer in
Cameroon you spend all your life
strolling to cultivate cocoa coffee
aroma cutting which you don't eat
they're called cash crop and that's
where the problem lies
big industry fix their prices not going
back to the farmer to consult them so it
means that the prices fall on top of
your head every year I am installing to
feed your family
the solution is to empower this farmer
so we link them to the market diversify
the source of income so you become less
vulnerable when the prices of this cash
crop 38
you
the reversal Center is an area where we
develop tree domestication of high-value
trees because we can eat cocoa
we can eat coffee these indigenous fruit
trees are part of the diet of the local
population 4 million years so what we
are trying to do is bring in format
where they can learn new innovation new
technique and how to multiply those
trees so they can be able to cut the
channel poverty in the rural area by
using agroforestry you restore sulphate
elite you control erosion and you
achieve a multi-purpose tree in one spot
area you select the llamada tree
according to the fruit they are already
producing if they are good big fruit
very suit fruit very colorful trip then
they are not the characteristic our
now the essential tool in three
domestication is to have sounded
planting material you can get them
through three different technique
routine market you have tea
it is to the farmer to choose the
technology which you ease it to him the
routine is the fastest one to produce
big number trees this is the easiest way
of producing selected material denti-cal
to the mother tree another technique we
are using is marketing you remove back
on 5 centimeter cover it with sawdust in
2-3 months you can see the routing
system another thing we use is grafting
you have what you call a root stock take
a branch which we call a scion and then
you attach it the routing system can go
deep in the soil and nourish the soil to
express itself that's the beauty of this
simplified technique well adapted to
rural area understandable to every type
of farmer the big idea behind the rural
center is to give the entrepreneurial
spirit to the farmer so we develop the
marketing skill we give them the
beginning skill so they get the right
price from their product and the Tomica
get back to the image feeling and be
proud of the agriculture they are doing
[Music]
[Music]